preliminary still a lot of uh interviews
and further investigation to go
what was the adult doing with the gun
were they kind of playing with it toying
with it are you
sure about that it's it's too early to
say at this point
uh no one's been arrested right now
still early still have interviews to do
to find out exactly
specifically the how and the why is what
i can't tell you and that's going to be
crucial to the uh investigation their
gender of the three-year-olds
uh it was a hispanic male
does the um three-year-old have a
relationship with this adult
um we're still trying to sort all that
out depending on
which adult um but the adult the
child was the son of one of the adults
there yes
outside in the parking lot how horrible
is something like this i mean any death
is
atrocious but especially you know a
young child like this
to die in a situation like this oh yeah
any shooting is
tragic but to look in the face of a
three-year-old as i just did
um it doesn't get much worse than that
uh and without a doubt regardless of
the intentions accidental
whatever absolutely that message needs
to go out to everybody
because unfortunately going too many of
these each year um
even being accidental whether it's
unsecured firearms
carelessness cleaning guns people need
to take
much better care of their firearms
because we do result
in too many investigations even the ones
that are not fatal
where we are responding to too many
houses with too many injuries
as a result of just negligence with
handling
and securing firearms so absolutely hope
everybody gets that message
was the one who called the mother of the
child no it was not it was one of the
friends
thank you
you